les élèves de 5e après les bases d'une
discussion s'écouter argumenté ne pas se
moquer thème du jour
sommes nous différents c'est quelque
chose qui est normal c'est quelque chose
qui nous semblent commun à tous et qu'on
pourrait voir son nouveau look et tous
ces élèves ont entre 11 et 12 ans et ont
chacun un rôle défini
jade prend des notes pour synthétiser le
propos d'autres discutent certains
observent sans s'exprimer
lewis et président de séance c'est lui
qui distribue la parole quelque chose
qui n'est pas bien trop gelé c'est
qu'ils parlent le moins comme martha et
par beaucoup du coup j'interroge ceux
qui sont qu'ils ont moins parler du coup
bas prix notre règle dans la classe
priorité aux petits parleurs du coup
j'ai interrogé tu parles heures pour les
élèves tout l'enjeu est d'arriver à
s'affirmer pour prendre la parole en
public
il ya des différences ça ne choque pas
mais les différences plus gros sous
c'est le choc prémont femmes les
personnes handicapées des fois ça nous
choque
mon objectif c'est que les élèves
puissent se dire que le voisin pensent
différemment que moi et que on doit
bâtir ensemble une réflexion commune
pour arriver à des positions
médiane afin de vivre ensemble au
collège inepte de sennecey-le-grand
tous les élèves de 5e participent à ce
cours d'eau khalid est quatre à cinq
fois par an